I'm ready to start. Welcomearks. Smarks. Smarks. Hey, yes, so Will is joining us from over the pond there in London. It looks like you went ahead and treated yourself to a nice, at least a one-bedroom, maybe a two-bedroom suite. Dude, look, who's counting other than you? I mean, yeah, it looks, uh, looks like you're doing pretty well. Yeah, sitting in a wing back. Sitting in a wing back, you know, I felt like this is the chair that I've always deserved. Yeah. You know, and you're also taught your kind of, you sound like you're keeping it down, because you're trying to stay in a cell phone. Yeah, you're trying to be quiet because the kids are asleep or you know, you know, you know why it's kind of echoey in here.
准备好了，我们开始吧。欢迎，Smarks。Smarks。Smarks。嘿，是的，威尔正在大洋彼岸的伦敦加入我们。看起来你给自己安排了一个不错的套房，至少有一间卧室，也许是两间。天哪，你看，除了你还有谁在数呢？我是说，看起来，呃，你过得挺不错的。对，坐在高背椅上。坐在高背椅上，你知道，我觉得这就是我一直应得的椅子。对。你知道的，而且你说话听起来好像压低了声音，因为你想留在手机里。对，你想保持安静，因为孩子们睡着了，或者你知道，你知道为什么这里听起来有点回音。
Yeah. So I'm just trying to be like not as echoey. Oh, because you probably have hardwood floors in that nice hotel and high ceilings, right? Sure do. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So I'm over here visiting some friends and then of course I'm going to the football on Sunday
对。所以我只是尽量不那么有回音。哦，因为你住的那家不错的酒店可能铺了硬木地板，而且天花板很高，对吧？确实如此。对。对。所以我在这里拜访一些朋友，当然周日我还要去看足球赛。
Which I'm really excited about the NFL is having a game on this this weekend over There's trying to expand the lead you are something you are something else. I am I'm going to see Liverpool Play West Ham up at Anfield their their home ground in Liverpool on Sunday. Chappie and I are going And I'm very, very excited. Mm-hmm. I can't. Would you ever consider getting each other rings, you and Chappy? Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
我真的很兴奋，NFL这周末在这边有一场比赛。他们正试图把联盟推广到……你真行，你真有一套。我是说，我周日要去看利物浦对阵西汉姆联的比赛，就在他们利物浦的主场安菲尔德。小皮和我一起去，我非常非常兴奋。嗯。我简直。你和查皮有没有考虑过给彼此买戒指？哈哈哈哈。
But you just tattoo it around your ring finger. You know, we went saw yesterday. We went last night, so Johnny Vaughn, my buddy who I've mentioned, who's on the radio over here, and he's a great talent. Oh, yeah. And so I went and joined the a great time. Oh, yeah. And so I went and joined the 4-0-7 thing with his crew.
但你可以直接在无名指上纹一个。你知道，我们昨天去看了。我们昨晚去了，约翰尼·方，我提过的我的哥们，他是这里的电台DJ，他很有才华。哦，是的。所以我也加入了。哦，是的。所以我也加入了加夫·伍德曼·伍兹到森特尔·坦普尔顿博士再到大西恩、莱拉·赛特的407活动，当时就是，然后我们在赌场吃了一顿美味的中餐晚餐。哦。
Everybody from Gav the Woodman Woods to Dr. Suntletempleton to Big Sion, Lilah Sight was just a, and then we went out for a nice Chinese food dinner at a casino. Oh. Yeah. How about that? Like a betting casino? It was, yeah, it was very, it was different, but it was great.
是的。觉得怎么样？像那种赌博赌场吗？是的，这很特别，但感觉很棒。
This guy hosted us. It was amazing and the credible Chinese food restaurant in the basement in the casino. Yeah. Good time, man. Good time, man. I can't picture, like adjacent space. I know.
这家伙招待了我们。这太棒了，而且赌场地下室里有一家极棒的中餐厅。是的，度过了一段美好的时光，伙计。度过了一段美好的时光，伙计。我无法想象，就像相邻的空间一样。我知道。
I can't picture anybody. I'm not a nerd. I can't picture gambling anywhere other than Vegas. So they have casinos there. Is it feel like Vegas? They got casinos everywhere, Sean. Really? Yeah. You ever heard of Macau?
我无法想象任何人……我可不是个书呆子。除了拉斯维加斯，我想象不出还在哪里能赌博。所以他们那里有赌场。感觉像拉斯维加斯吗？他们到处都是赌场，肖恩。真的吗？对。你听说过澳门吗？
I, uh, I'm going to be going to Vegas in a, a few weeks here and I'm, uh, anticipating not going to the tables at all because I don't drink anymore. And I feel like I need to be inebriated to enjoy the mindlessness of gambling and the fear of gambling. Sean, Sean, Sean can do it at breakfast. Yeah, that's true. I can do it. Oh, true. I could do it.
我，呃，过几周就要去拉斯维加斯了，我，呃，预计到时候根本不会去赌桌旁，因为我已经不喝酒了。我觉得我需要喝醉才能享受赌博的无脑和赌博带来的恐惧。肖恩，肖恩，肖恩在早餐时就能做到。是的，这倒也是。我能做到。哦，没错。我能做到。
Oh, my God. I love it. Wait, Sean, are you one of those at like a buffet? Do you sit at the table, fill out the bingo cart and everything? Yeah, and then I go to Vegas. I went with Sean once. You remember that years ago we went to Tobago's. Oh, my God.
噢，天哪。我太喜欢了。等等，肖恩，你是在自助餐时会做这种事的人吗？你会坐在桌旁，填好宾果卡和所有东西吗？对，然后我去拉斯维加斯。我和肖恩去过一次。你还记得多年前我们去过多巴哥吗？哦，天哪。
There was a long time ago. You remember that? That was like 2002. Was this after a stumble, you guys? It was before it. It was before. It guys? Uh, it was before it was before. It was before. Yeah. Well, before I got I went to Vegas.
那是很久以前的事了。你还记得吗？那大概是2002年。你们这是在跌倒之后吗？是在那之前。在那之前。伙计们？呃，是在那之前，是在那之前。是在那之前。是的。好吧，在我去拉斯维加斯之前。
But, but maybe after Venice, uh, boy, because we've been in Venice Italy too. Does Chad know about Sean? Is he okay with him? I'm trying to keep him on. Well, well, and I have tattooed rings. Toe rings. But Sean, I saw Sean one time at the blackjack table, just go nuts and he was splitting and doubling
但是，但是也许在威尼斯之后，呃，孩子，因为我们也去过意大利威尼斯。查德知道肖恩的事吗？他对他还好吧？我正试图让他继续。好吧，好吧，我和我有纹过的戒指。脚趾环。但是肖恩，我有一次看到肖恩在二十一点赌桌上，简直疯狂了，他当时在分牌和双倍下注。
down. And at one point, he just had, he was playing like an eight hand thing. It was so many splits. Yeah, it was two dollar units, right? It's just a two dollar table. No, it was great. And that one time, I think it was that time or you want. Yeah, I kept winning. I was really drunk and I was really young.
而且一度，他甚至在玩八手牌的游戏。有那么多的分牌。对，那是两美元的筹码，对吧？那只是个两美元的桌子。不，那太棒了。还有那一次，我想就是那次，你赢了。对，我一直在赢。我当时喝得烂醉，而且年纪还小。
See, that's what I mean. I don't think you can win when you're sober. No, and yeah, because you make horrible choices. Well, you make pragmatic decisions and that's sort of at odds with successful gambling, I think. Yeah, and I, anyway, I had like 300 bucks or 200 bucks left or something like that. And I'd turn it into like 10,000 bucks
你看，这就是我的意思。我觉得你清醒的时候是不可能赢的。不，是的，因为你会做出糟糕的选择。好吧，你会做出功利的决定，这和成功的赌博有点冲突，我觉得。对，而且我，不管怎样，我身上大概还剩300块或者200块钱左右之类的。然后我把它变成大约1万块钱。
and I gave it all the way to the people at the table. The people. Yeah. Robin Hood. Like the, like, like, just like, probably a second. If you work for the IRS, if you work for the IRS, it was 9,9999, right? How are you with the, how are you with the jet lag? Can you, I'm okay. Really fast. You kind of hit me. I actually left in her a little bit early, because the jet lag kind of hit me in the between the eyes.
然后我把钱全给桌上的人了。那些人。对。罗宾汉。就像，就像，就像，可能也就一秒钟。如果你在国税局工作，如果你在国税局工作，那是9,9999美元，对吧？你对时差反应感觉怎么样？你能，我还可以。好得很快。你有点把我给击中了。其实我有点起得太早了，因为时差反应有点直奔我的双眼袭来。
And I was like, guys, I got to go to sleep. But I can tell you this, I'm really excited to go to my first, as you guys know, I do love Liverpool and I love what they call football over here. So I'm excited to go. It's a big thrill. And Jay is a sports fan. You can appreciate how cool it is to go to a new stadium. Yeah.
然后我就想，伙计们，我得去睡觉了。但我可以告诉你的是，我真的很高兴去看我的第一场比赛，正如你们所知，我确实热爱利物浦，我也热爱他们这里所谓的足球。所以我很兴奋能去。这真是个巨大的刺激。杰伊是个体育迷。你能体会到去一个新的体育场有多酷。对。
They make sports fans look bad here in the States because you guys got the, they guys, you're appreciate how cool it is to go to a new, yeah, they make sports fans look bad here in the States, because you guys got the, or they guys, you're, you're one of them. They, they, all the songs that you sang are incredible. It's real good fan stuff all that. I'd be into that. It's super, super fun. It's a great environment. I've only been to one match over in Europe and that was in Spain a few years ago, but I haven't been here and I'm so excited. And I love the football. And I'm glad I'm saying football because it's reminding me. Oh, here you go. It's reminding me and the guests. Watch us.
他们让美国的体育迷相形见绌，因为你们有，他们有，你体会到去一个新的，对，他们让美国的体育迷相形见绌，因为你们有，或者他们有，你，你就是他们中的一员。他们，他们唱的所有歌曲都棒极了。这真的是很好的球迷文化，所有这些。我会喜欢这个的。超级超级有趣。这是一个很棒的氛围。我在欧洲只去过一场比赛，那是几年前在西班牙，但我还没来过这里，我太兴奋了。我喜欢足球。我很高兴我一直在说“足球”，因为这提醒了我。哦，给你。这提醒了我还有嘉宾。看着我们。
You know, our guest today, I'm so excited because I just want to get to him. Okay, well, our guest today is an incredible entrepreneur. He's a philanthropist. He's involved in all sorts of businesses from media consulting to management, to blenders, to sports apparel, to team ownership. This is a guy who's done so much, and it started, a lot of it started
你知道，我们今天的嘉宾，我太兴奋了，因为我只想直接和他聊聊。好吧，我们今天的嘉宾是一位杰出的企业家。他是一位慈善家。他涉足各种各样的业务，从媒体咨询、管理、搅拌机、运动服饰到球队所有权。这是一个取得了巨大成就的人，而这一切，很大一部分开始于……
because he had so much success on the farm field. And you know, you talk about people who do amazing things, and then you talk about guys who are went in the first round of the NFL draft, who played three seasons in both football field. And you know, you talk about people who do amazing things. And then you talk about guys who were when in the first round of the NFL draft, who played three seasons and both of them. And twice led the league in touchdowns, voted to four consecutive pro-Bulls. And one of Super Bowl. And also, I think he got really well known for his incredible, what they called the Beast Quake, what touched down run. What during the 2010-2011 NFL playoffs, he rushed 67 yards while breaking nine tackles, considered one of the greatest NFL runs of all time.
因为他在农田赛场上取得了巨大的成功。你知道，你谈论那些做过惊人事情的人，然后你谈论那些在NFL选秀首轮被选中、在橄榄球场上效力了三个赛季的家伙。你知道，你谈论那些做过惊人事情的人。然后你谈论那些在NFL选秀首轮被选中、在两个赛场上效力了三个赛季的家伙。并且两次领跑联盟达阵榜，连续四次入选职业碗。赢得过超级碗。而且我也觉得他因为那次极其精彩的被称为“野兽震动”的达阵冲球而广为人知。在2010-2011赛季NFL季后赛期间，他在打破九次拦截的情况下冲刺了67码，被认为是NFL历史上最伟大的冲球之一。
He's an all-time great, he's an all-time great guy, and he's also more importantly, my friend. You guys, it's Mr. Marshawn Lynch. No way. Marshawn. Marshawn, good morning. Marshawn. Who's going on?
他是一个历史级别的伟大人物，一个历史级别的伟大家伙，而且更重要的是，他是我的朋友。伙计们，这就是马肖恩·林奇先生。不会吧。马肖恩。马肖恩，早上好。马肖恩。最近怎么样？
Oh my gosh. Marcia, can I ask you a question? Why do you spend so much time with this guy, Will, or not? What happened? Does he have photos on you or something? You guys are so close. It's the weirdest couple in all of Hollywood.
哦，天哪。马肖恩，我能问你个问题吗？你为什么花那么多时间跟这家伙威尔在一起？怎么回事？他手里有你的照片什么的吗？你们俩太亲密了。这是整个好莱坞最奇怪的一对。
Nah, man, you did. I told him, if you ever call my phone, bang my line, I'll bang my line. I'm gonna make it work. Cause he gave me an opportunity to do some shit that I ain't never done before. So anytime you hit my phone, I mean, I'm coming through phone. So that's just forever.
不，伙计，你才……我告诉过他，如果你打我的电话，轰炸我的热线，我也会打回去。我会促成它的。因为他给了我一个机会，去做一些我从未做过的事情。所以只要你打我电话，我是说，我一定随叫随到。所以这就永远有效。
In perpetuity, he's got you as a guy throwing favors. If for sure. Can we know what that was or no? No, murder view. Yeah. A lot of people don't want to tap it. Can we know what that was or no? No, murder view. Yeah. A lot of people don't realize how hilarious Marshall is. Yeah. Because they think of him as like a football icon.
永远有效，他把你当成了专门帮忙的人。那是肯定的。我们能知道那是什么事吗，还是不能说？不，谋杀审判。是的。很多人没有意识到。我们能知道那是什么事吗，还是不能说？不，谋杀审判。是的。很多人没有意识到马肖恩有多搞笑。是的。因为他们认为他就像一个橄榄球偶像。
And I'm like, this is a funny dude. And I'm so lucky. You know, I'm so happy that you do return my calls. And you know, Marshall, we've never really talked about football, like in a way, or like, how you started. I think about it. Over the last few years, we've talked about so much other weird stuff. Honeymoon.
而我想：这家伙真逗。我太幸运了。你知道，我太高兴你真的会回我的电话了。而且你知道，马肖恩，我们从来没有真正聊过橄榄球，比如从某种方式，或者你是怎么开始的。我想想看。在过去的几年里，我们聊了那么多其他奇怪的事情。蜜月。
And we went, oh, well, we went, we covered the World Cup last year. We did this thing together. And we never talked about how you started in pro, well, just in football in general. And I guess that's on me I should have asked. But I'm asking now, how did you, what was your first, when you in love with football, when you first started, when you were a kid, like, what was the deal? What was your relationship like with football starting out? No, I mean, the relationship with football was, I was, I was big on playing it, not too much of a, not too much of a fan of sitting down and watching it.
我们去了，哦，我们去，我们去年报道了世界杯。我们一起做了这件事。我们从没有聊过你是怎么开始接触职业橄榄球的，或者只是怎么开始接触橄榄球的。我想这是我的错，我本该问的。但我现在要问了，你是怎么，你的第一次，是什么时候爱上橄榄球的？当你刚开始的时候，当你还是个孩子的时候，比如，那是怎么回事？你刚开始时和橄榄球是什么关系？不，我是说，我对橄榄球的关系是，我很喜欢踢它，但不太喜欢，不太喜欢坐下来看它。
Really? When it came to it, it was like, yeah, if we had the opportunity, every opportunity I had to play it, I was for sure getting down. But I really wasn't, I wasn't, like I said, I wasn't big on sitting down and watching the game. It wasn't like, like a big-ass tradition that we did where everybody come through on Sunday and watch the games or, you know, Monday nights wasn't like, we got to watch this Thursday and not, I wasn't no shit like that and then the opportunity to go to college and, you
真的吗？说到这个，这就好像，是的，如果我们有机会，我每一次有机会去玩，我肯定会大干一场。但我真的不是，我不是，就像我说的，我不喜欢坐下来看比赛。这不像是什么大得不得了的传统，大家会在周日聚在一起看比赛，或者，你知道的，周一晚上也不像，我们必须看这个，周四也不像，我才没有搞那种鬼把戏呢，然后有机会去上大学，然后，
know, play there. And I thought it would all end for me after high school and then, you know, play there. I thought it would all end for me after high school. And then, you know, we start sending letters like, oh, yeah, you got opportunities to go to college and shit. That wasn't something that was, you know, really talked about in my household as well. So, really? And it just all seemed, yeah, that shit all seemed
你知道，在那里打球。我以为这一切在我高中毕业后就会对我结束，然后，你知道，在那里打球。我以为这一切在我高中毕业后就会对我结束。然后，你知道，我们开始收到信件说，哦，是的，你有机会去上大学之类的。那并不是在我家里经常谈论的事情。所以，真的吗？而这一切看起来，是的，那所有这一切看起来……
like a little fairy tale or whatever, but. Which colleges you ended up going to? Cal. University. Oh, yeah. California? Yeah. So I mean, the shoe worked out for me in the long run, but yeah, for sure.
就像一个小童话什么的，但是。你最后去了哪所大学？加州大学。大学。哦，是的。加利福尼亚？对。所以我的意思是，从长远来看，这双鞋挺适合我的，但是，是的，肯定的。
When I first found out, I'm like, hell, no, you want me, you want me go to more school? Like, I'm more voluntary school. Oh, yeah. Like, no, hell, no, I'm cool off that. I ain't a lot, luckily I had two cousins who was really into that shit. Was that schoolwork?
当我第一次发现的时候，我想，见鬼，不，你想让我，你想让我去上更多学？就像，我要去上自愿学校。哦，是的。就像，不，见鬼，不，我对这个不感兴趣。说实话，幸运的是我有两个表亲对这破事真的很感兴趣。是学校作业吗？
Yeah, for sure. For sure. Really into schoolwork. Yeah, man. I say they took on the jobs of the teachers by making sure I maintained a reasonable grade point average to even be able to give college opportunities. That's awesome. But then once it was like, once I got there
对，肯定的。肯定的。对学校作业真的很感兴趣。对，伙计。我说他们承担了老师的工作，确保我保持合理的平均绩点，甚至能够获得上大学的机会。那太棒了。但一旦到了那种地步，一旦我到了那里……
and you know, seeing what type of time that was on what I had to do, I don't order to accomplish, you know, going to the next level, then shit just made sense. And it was like, that shit clicked. Because now I was like, oh, I gotta go, and I gotta do X, Y, and Z to accomplish this.
并且你知道，看到了那是什么节奏，我必须做什么，为了实现目标，你知道，进入下一个水平，然后事情就顺理成章了。这就开窍了。因为现在我想，哦，我得去，我得做X、Y和Z来完成这个。
Then let me just do what I need to do. I see how far I could take. Do you remember the process of getting used to getting hit? Like, did you start playing football so you were on for him? Or you don't remember it? Were you so young when you started that you don't remember it? Or do you remember? Like, because I never was allowed to play football.
那就让我做我需要做的事吧。我看看我能走多远。你还记得习惯被撞击的过程吗？比如，你开始打橄榄球时年纪还小吗？还是你不记得了？你开始的时候太小所以不记得了？还是你还记得？因为我从来都不被允许打橄榄球。
My mom was British. She wanted me to play soccer. But I got this one part in a football movie where I actually got to put on pads in the helmet and I played like a defensive back or something. And this one, this one take, I had to tackle a guy. And I didn't know what to do with my head. I felt like, well, if my head hits that person's shoulder, it's gonna break my neck. So what I thought would know what to do with my head. I felt like, well, if my head hits that person's shoulder,
我妈妈是英国人。她想让我踢足球。但我曾在一部橄榄球电影里演过一个小角色，我真的戴上了护具和头盔，我踢的是防守后卫还是什么的。在其中一个镜头里，我必须去擒抱一个人。我不知道该拿我的头怎么办。我觉得，如果我的头撞到那家伙的肩膀上，会把我的脖子撞断。所以我想知道该拿我的头怎么办。我觉得，如果我的头撞到那家伙的肩膀上，
it's gonna break my neck. So what I thought would be smart to do is just to kind of shrug my shoulders up and trap my helmet in the hole that the shoulder pads create. So it's locked in there. Like a turtle. Yeah, exactly. I'm not sure when you did this, this rolling that movie,
会把我的脖子撞断。所以我认为聪明的做法是把肩膀耸起来，把头盔塞进肩垫制造的那个洞里。这样它就锁在里面了。像一只乌龟。对， exatamente。我不太确定你是什么时候拍的那部电影，
but you sound like you, you got that move from the little giants. Exactly. I'm just a small soft actor and they all laughed at me. The movie was a comedy, thank God. But that's right, though, Jay, I wouldn't think of that. That is true. Like, because, Marcia, I'm the opposite of you.
但听起来你，你这招是从《小巨人》里学来的。没错。我只是个柔弱的小演员，他们都嘲笑我。谢天谢地，那部电影是个喜剧。不过话说得对，杰伊，我可不会想到那一点。确实如此。因为，马肖恩，我跟你正好相反。
I'd rather watch it than play it. And because I played it when I was a kid, I was terrible. But when I watch it, then when I see the heads hit the bodies, I think the same thing. I was like, how does their neck? Yeah. So do you remember that process? Was there a learning curve that's painful on that
我宁愿看也不愿踢。因为我小时候踢过，我踢得太烂了。但当我看着它的时候，当我看到脑袋撞击身体时，我想的是同一件事。我就想，他们的脖子怎么……对。所以你还记得那个过程吗？在这个过程中，有一个痛苦的学习曲线，
or were you too young? Most definitely. So I mean, I got the, I probably got the latest start. Because it was a group of us. And I mean, you know, it was more family, you know, close friends like in the neighborhood. And, you know, I think I was probably one of the later ones that started maybe around age 13.
还是你太年轻了？绝对是的。所以我的意思是，我，我可能是最晚开始的。因为我们是一群人。我的意思是，你知道的，更多的是家人，你知道，像社区里的好朋友。而且，你知道，我想我可能是比较晚开始的一个，大概在13岁左右吧。
Yeah. So a few of them started maybe age six, six, eight was around the normal time for them to start. So they were called like considered the veterans, right? And you know, one of my closest friends, recipes, we were doing hidden drills, it's an angle in tackling. It's the biggest thing in football. And uh, is what is angle tackling? Angle in tackling. Tackling drill. What does that mean? Is you line up on opposite sides, put a cone out, and you come to a point where you have to earn your manhood.
对。所以他们中有些人可能在六岁、六到八岁左右就开始了，这对他们来说是正常的时间。所以他们被称为所谓的“老兵”，对吧？你知道，我最亲密的其中一个朋友，雷斯佩斯，我们在做撞击训练，那是角度擒抱。这是橄榄球里最重要的事情。而且呃，“角度擒抱”是什么？角度擒抱。擒抱训练。那是什么意思？就是你们在相对的两侧排好队，放一个标志筒，然后你们在一个点相遇，在那里你必须证明自己是个男子汉。
It's not a lot of a, sure. A lot of it. We're a lot of a saying it. And you know, he was a veteran. This was my first year, and my first year in full contact sports. And somehow he convinced me to go first, which, you know what I mean, was not a good idea, but... So he called Goat and we ran and we hit.
这可不是闹着玩的，当然。这有很多讲究。而且你知道，他是老兵。这是我的第一年，也是我第一年参加全接触体育运动。不知怎么的，他居然说服我先上，你知道我的意思，这可不是个好主意，但是……所以他喊了“开始”，我们冲过去，撞在了一起。
Like a couple of rams hitting each other with their horns, right? Yeah, except for I didn't lower my shoulders or my helmet. And I went in standing straight up like I was trying to give him a barehood. Like Frank had actually put a stomach exactly. He actually put his helmet right in my stomach. Ouch. And I'm talking about all the wind with blow. I was like, oh, shit, I don't know.
就像两只公羊用角撞击对方一样，对吧？对，只不过我没有压低肩膀，也没有压低头盔。我直挺挺地冲了进去，就像我想给他一个熊抱一样。就像弗兰克真的把肚子放上去一样。他真的把头盔直接顶在我的肚子上了。哎哟。我是说，所有的气一下子都被撞出来了。我当时想：哦，见鬼，我不知道。
And I had to make a decision because, as soon as the, you know what I mean? As soon as he had hidden, all you can hear is the coaches. Like, man, what the hell y'all doing? Like, line up. And I'm like, line up. Like, oh, you want me to do this again? I'm laying down.
我必须做一个决定，因为，一旦……你懂我的意思吗？一旦他撞过来，你唯一能听到的就是教练的声音。就像：伙计，你们到底在搞什么鬼？快排好队。而我心想：排好队？哦，你是想让我再来一次吗？我正躺在地上呢。
Yeah. You want me to do this again, right after? I'm like, I don't know what to say. I'm gonna tell him, like, hey, you know, I just went. But then you know, everybody in line, they, hey, line up, line up, you gotta line it up. Coach, you said, my, so I'm gonna tell him, hey, you know, I just went. But then you know, everybody in line, hey, line up, line up, you gotta line it up, hold your shit up. So I'm like, oh, you want me to do this again? So it was like, hell no, I seen what you just did to me.
对。你想让我紧接着再来一次吗？我当时想：我不知道该说啥。我打算告诉他，嘿，你知道的，我刚刚才上过。但你知道的，排队的每个人都在喊：嘿，排好队，排好队，你得排好队。教练，你刚才说，我的……所以我打算告诉他，嘿，你知道的，我刚刚才上过。但你知道的，排队的每个人都在喊：嘿，排好队，排好队，你得排好队，把你的破事收拾好。所以我心想：哦，你想让我再来一次？所以当时的想法是：见鬼，我刚看清你对我做了什么。
And I was like, all right, now this time, I'm a duck not showed in my head and running into you. So the thing was, I was a little faster than him, so I was able to get to the point quicker than him. So in the midst of him, lowering his helmet and his shoulders, I had already been lowered in the smashing. Bam! Couches like, oh, okay.
然后我想：好吧，这次我要把头缩起来，用头撞你。所以事情是这样的，我比他稍微快一点，所以我能比他更快到达那个点。就在他压低头盔和肩膀的时候，我已经压低了身子，狠狠地撞了上去。砰！教练说：哦，好吧。
Little rookie got something to him. Line up again. And now he's calling on his veterans to the front of the line and now he want to see the rookie hit with all the veterans and so it was a thing to like all this is just what you got to do in order to be you know a hitter on the team knows the people who get all the praise all the cheerleaders make love go numbered you know what I mean whoever your number number is. And I'm like, oh shit. So if I become a hitter then I could be one of them. And then I mean, you know, my first position I play offensive line.
小菜鸟还有两下子嘛。再排好队。现在他把老兵们叫到队伍最前面，现在他想看看这个菜鸟跟所有老兵一起撞击，所以这是一件……这就是为了成为队里的“重击手”你必须做的事情，那些得到所有赞美、啦啦队员都爱慕的人，不管你是几号，你知道我的意思，不管你的球衣号码是几号。我心想：哦，见鬼。所以如果我能成为一个重击手，那我就可以成为他们的一员了。然后我的意思是，你知道，我打的第一个位置是进攻线。
So that's where all my little, there's my toughness and all that, ain't afraid to hit somebody and then, you know, as much as so for y'all who don't know, I'm an offensive player, but my mentality is defense. And we will be right back. Smarlas has brought to you in part by GoodRx. Cold and flu season is an unfortunate reality.
所以这就是我所有那些……这就是我的强悍之处，我不怕撞人，然后，我的意思是，对于你们这些不知道的人来说，我是一个进攻球员，但我的心态是防守型的。我们马上回来。SmarLess部分内容由GoodRx赞助播出。感冒和流感季节是一个不幸的现实。
But if you're feeling under the weather, GoodRx is here to help with big savings on prescription cold and flu medicine. Tons of information to help you and your family stay healthy this fall. With good R-axis, you can instantly find discounts, compare prices, and save up to 80% of the pharmacy. All you need to do is search for your medication on the good R-axis website or app and show your discounted pharmacy.
但如果你觉得身体不舒服，GoodRx可以为你提供帮助，让你在处方感冒药和流感药上享受大额折扣。这里有大量的信息，可以帮助你和你的家人在这个秋天保持健康。通过GoodRx，你可以在药店立即找到折扣、比较价格并节省高达80%的费用。你只需要在GoodRx网站或应用程序上搜索你的药物，然后出示给你的折扣药店即可。
It's that easy. Good R-axis accepted at all the major pharmacies in your neighborhood, including CBS, Walgreens, R-I-D, Bonds, Walmart, Sam's Club, and many more. And remember, good Rx isn't not insurance, but it works whether you have insurance or not. Even if you have insurance, good Rx may beat your copay price. For big savings on cold and flu meds, plus discounts on your everyday prescriptions, go to goodrx.com slash smartless.
就是这么简单。GoodRx被你家附近的所有主要药店接受，包括CVS、Walgreens、Rite Aid、Vons、Walmart、Sam's Club等等。记住，GoodRx不是保险，但无论你是否有保险它都管用。即使你有保险，GoodRx的价格也可能比你的自付额还要便宜。想要在感冒和流感药物上省大钱，并享受日常处方的折扣，请访问goodrx.com/smartless。
Be sure to use our URL so they know we sent you. That's goodrx.com slash smartless. Be sure to use our URL so they know we sent you. That's goodRx.com slash smartless. Smartless is sponsored by BetterHelp. So it's that time of the year. It's the end of the year. You know, the holidays, some people may struggle with seasonal blues. You know, some people have like family stuff
请务必使用我们的网址，这样他们就知道是我们介绍你来的。网址是 goodrx.com/smartless。请务必使用我们的网址，这样他们就知道是我们介绍你来的。网址是 GoodRx.com/smartless。SmartLess由BetterHelp赞助。所以又到了这个时候。一年快过完了。你知道的，节日期间，有些人可能会陷入季节性抑郁。你知道的，有些人有一些家庭问题……
that they don't wanna address and it kind of brings them down. So, you know, you have to show up, as they say, for Thanksgiving and show up for Christmas with the family. And there's, you know, a lot to argue about, a lot to have anxiety about. But, you know what helps with all that? If you talk to somebody, a therapist. This time of year can be a lot, and it's natural to feel some sadness or anxiety about it. But adding something new and positive to your life can counteract some of those feelings. Therapy can be a bright spot amid all the stress and change. Something to look forward to to make you feel grounded and to give you the tools to manage
他们不想去面对，这会让他们感到沮丧。所以，正如他们所说，你必须在感恩节露面，在圣诞节和家人一起露面。而且，你知道，有很多争论的话题，有很多让人焦虑的事情。但是，你知道什么能帮到这一切吗？如果你找个人聊聊，一个治疗师。每到这个时候，生活可能会变得压力山大，对这一切感到一些悲伤或焦虑是很自然的。但在你的生活中加入一些新鲜而积极的事情可以抵消其中一些负面情绪。在所有的压力和变化中，心理治疗可以成为一个亮点。这是你所期待的事情，能让你感到脚踏实地，并为你提供管理一切的工具……
everything going on. I always add a little extra session to my therapy routine around these times for many, many reasons. And you know, it always helps. It always feels good. And, you know, and it's true, it's something to look forward to to kind of get all of that stuff out of your brain and into somebody else's. So if you're thinking of starting therapy, give better help, a try.
在这些时候，我总是在我的心理治疗常规中额外增加一次咨询，原因有很多很多。而且你知道，这总是有帮助的。这总是让人感觉很好。而且，你知道，这是真的，这确实是一件值得期待的事情，可以把所有这些东西从你的大脑里排解出去，转移到别人的脑子里。所以如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试BetterHelp。
It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just spill out of breathe questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist, and switch therapists any time for no additional charge. Find your bright spot this season with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartless today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelpaglp.com slash smartless. Thanks to Helix for supporting Smartless. As you know, we've talked a lot about these matches, how great they are, the best sleep ever. I got the Helix Dusk Lux mattress.
它完全在网上进行，旨在方便、灵活，并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与持有执照的治疗师匹配，而且可以随时免费更换治疗师。在这个季节用BetterHelp找到你的亮点。今天就访问 betterhelp.com/smartless，首月可享9折优惠。网址是 betterhelpaglp.com/smartless。感谢Helix对SmartLess的支持。如你所知，我们聊了很多关于这些床垫的话题，它们有多棒，这是有史以来最好的睡眠。我买的是Helix Dusk Lux床垫。
It's incredible. I lay down and I'll go nine and I real fast. The Helix lineup offers 20 unique mattresses, including the award-winning Lux Collection, the newly released Helix Elite Collection, a mattress designed for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for kids. Alright, so the Helix Elite Collection, it includes designed for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for kids. Alright, so the Helix Elite Collection, it includes six different mattress models, each tailored for specific sleep positions, and firmness preferences. Nervous about buying a mattress online, don't be!
这太不可思议了。我躺下去，九点钟就能睡着，而且入睡极快。Helix产品线提供20种独特的床垫，包括屡获殊荣的Lux系列、新发布的Helix Elite系列、专为高大身材睡眠者设计的床垫，甚至还有专为儿童制造的床垫。好吧，所以Helix Elite系列，它包括专为高大身材睡眠者设计的床垫，甚至还有专为儿童制造的床垫。好吧，所以Helix Elite系列，它包括六种不同的床垫型号，每一种都专为特定的睡眠姿势和软硬偏好量身定制。在网上买床垫感到紧张？大可不必！
The Helix Sleep Quiz takes into account your individual sleep preferences to match you and your partner with the perfect mattress for you. And your personalized mattresses shipped straight to your door, free of charge. Don't want to take my word. Helix Sleep has over 12,000 five star reviews. Helix is offering 20% off all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners.
Helix睡眠测试会考虑你的个人睡眠偏好，为你和你的伴侣匹配最完美的床垫。而且你定制的床垫会直接免费运送到你的门前。不想听我一面之词？Helix Sleep拥有超过12,000条五星好评。Helix为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单8折优惠以及两个免费枕头。
Go to helix sleep.com slash smartless. This is their best offer yet, and it won't last long. With Helix better sleep starts now. By supporting Helix, you're allowing them to support the show. Go purchase your Helix and thank us later for your best night's sleep, helix.com slash, SmartLess. And now back to the show.
请访问 helixsleep.com/smartless。这是他们迄今为止最好的优惠，而且不会持续太久。有了Helix，更好的睡眠从现在开始。通过支持Helix，你也在让他们支持这个节目。快去购买你的Helix床垫吧，你以后会为自己拥有了有史以来最好的睡眠而感谢我们的，网址是 helixsleep.com/smartless。现在让我们回到节目中。
By playing offensive line first, do you have sympathy for the offensive lineman that once you became a running back, power back? You start running into the backs of the offensive lineman that once you became a running back power back? You start running into the backs of those offensive lineman. Do you remember the days when running back? You used to do that to you. I bet it hurts. No, man.
通过先打进攻线，当你后来成为一名跑卫、强力跑卫时，你对进攻线球员会有同情心吗？当你开始撞向那些进攻线球员的背部时……当你后来成为一名跑卫、强力跑卫时。你开始撞向那些进攻线球员的背部。你还记得当跑卫的日子吗？你以前也会对他们那样做。我敢打赌这很痛。不，伙计。
To be honest with you, I take care of my offensive lineman. And one of the things that I don't do is I don't run into the back of him. I read it. If I see a pile up or something like that, I read it, you know what I mean? I bounce outside and run into it, defender, then hit my office and lineman in the back. Is that something that offensive lineman
说实话，我挺照顾我的进攻线球员的。我不会做的一件事就是，我不会一头撞向他们的后背。我会观察形势。如果我看到有一堆人挤在一起或者类似的情况，我会观察局势，你知道我的意思吗？我会绕到外侧去撞防守球员，而不是撞击我的进攻线球员的后背。这是进攻线球员……
do complain about? Yeah, yeah. Yeah. This is like damn, pick your eyes up. Because they feel like, hey, look, I'm doing my job. I'm running this dude out of there and you running into my back. If you want to hit somebody, hit, yeah, I think I was the other color. Yeah.
会抱怨的事情吗？对，对。这就好像：该死，把你的眼睛睁大点。因为他们觉得，嘿，听着，我在做我的工作，我在把这家伙赶出去，而你却撞在我的后背上。如果你想撞人，去撞，对，我想那是另外一种颜色。对。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. During the, the, well, was work harder during football or was work harder now with the acting, you know, because the, the hours in acting can be, you know, usually 12 hours. And sometimes that hard work is simply trying to manage boredom because no one, there's
对。对。对。在，嗯……是踢球时的工作更辛苦，还是现在演戏的工作更辛苦？你知道的，因为演戏的工作时间可能，通常是12小时。有时那种辛苦实际上只是在试图对付无聊，因为没有人……
no two people that are working at the same time. And concentration though when you're cocking it's calling right? Yeah, or was the football harder because of, you know, all the obvious parts of it, the traveling and the strenuousness? Well, see the thing was, you know, the traveling, meetings, you know, practiced gangs, being able to take care of my body, you know, making sure I don't lose my mind. That became like second nature. That was more so like just my walk in life.
没有两个人是在同时工作的。不过当你拍摄时需要集中注意力，对吧？是的，或者说橄榄球更辛苦是因为，你知道的，所有显而易见的原因，比如旅行和剧烈运动？嗯，情况是这样的，你知道的，旅行、开会、你知道的，训练比赛、照顾好我的身体、确保我不会疯掉。那变得就像是第二天性。那更像是我生活中的一种常态。
And then with this, you know, with, you know, going over and to, I guess you would call it entertainment. It's more of like a challenge to me. So I'm not looking at it as is it harder, is it strenuous, it's more so like, I wanna understand it. Yeah. I wanna, I wanna so like, I want to understand it. Yeah. I want to, I want to get a, I want to get an understanding for this, the way that I did for when I was playing my sport.
然后对于这个，随着，随着你去做，我想你可以称之为娱乐行业的事。这对我来说更像是一个挑战。所以我并不认为它更难，或者更吃力，它更像是：我想理解它。对。我想，我想……所以就像：我想理解它。对。我想，我想对这个有所了解，就像我当年打球时那样。
But ultimately, if I'm just looking at it from a time management point, when I, when I locked in for football, I had to lock in for eight months out the year. That was just what it was. Right. Carlos. And why is it, why is it important to you just not have curiosity? I had to lock in for eight months out the year. That was just what it was, right? Garless. And why is it important to you just out of curiosity? Like, have you always had this thing in the back of your head? It's like, you know what?
但归根结底，如果我只从时间管理的角度来看，当我专注于橄榄球时，我一年中有八个月必须全神贯注。事情就是这样，对吧。卡洛斯。为什么，为什么对你来说，仅仅出于好奇心，去拥有这种……我一年中有八个月必须全神贯注。事情就是这样，对吧。加利斯。为什么，为什么对你来说，仅仅出于好奇心？比如，你的脑海深处一直有这样一种想法：你知道吗？
I want to stretch this muscle in my head about this acting thing or this artistic kind of side of me. No, it's just that real easily. I don't want to be bad. Yeah. Because I mean shit. I mean, you know, you hear about it all the time, like, for individuals after they first career, they go and get into something else and it kind of don't pan out for them. Right.
我想在演艺这件事情上，或者在我这种艺术倾向的一面上，锻炼一下我脑子里的肌肉。不，很简单，我只是不想表现得很糟糕。是的。因为我的意思是，见鬼。我的意思是，你知道的，你总是听到这种事，比如，个人在他们的第一职业生涯结束后，他们去涉足其他领域，结果却并不顺利。对。
And the same breath in which, you know, damn, he was a great football player or he was a good football. However, you view me as a football player, you're not going to say I was bad. And that's I've done something to your team. Right. Then then maybe I'm shitty to you, but otherwise, yeah, I mean, but otherwise you're going to say, yeah, I mean, he, he brought something to the game and then, you know, I mean,
在某种程度上，你知道，该死，他是个伟大的橄榄球运动员，或者他是个优秀的橄榄球运动员。不管你如何看待我作为橄榄球运动员的表现，你都不会说我很差劲。那是我对你们球队做出了贡献。对。那也许我对你来说是个混蛋，但除此之外，是的，我的意思是，但除此之外你会说，是的，我的意思是，他，他为比赛带来了价值，然后，你知道我的意思，
going into my second career and my fucking senior to like, oh, you know, where he ain't bad. He did it. He did a good job. So like it's almost like a challenge, like a, more fucking C.M.L.T. like, oh, you know where he ain't bad. He did a good job. So it's almost like a challenge. Like you enjoy the challenge of it. Yeah, I would say that. What about the, what about the gym? I imagine the gym would have been a big part of every day during your football career.
进入我的第二职业生涯，在我的第一年就让人觉得：哦，你知道吗，他其实不赖。他干得不错。所以这几乎就像是一个挑战，就像更该死的是，哦，你知道吗，他其实不赖。他干得不错。所以这几乎就像是一个挑战。就像你很享受这种挑战。是的，我会这么说。那健身房呢？我猜在你橄榄球生涯的每一天里，健身房都会占据很大一部分时间。
Is it this, are you, what's the amount of hours you're doing in the gym per week? To be honest with you, that was probably the place where I spent the least. Really? Worked out. I mean, you got to think about it. If you, my career, I played in the league with 12, 13 years and then you got to think college was another three high school four, little league. I got about three in.
是这样吗？你每周在健身房花多少小时？说实话，那可能是我花时间最少的地方。真的吗？锻炼。我的意思是，你得想想。如果，我的职业生涯，我在联盟里打了12、13年，然后你还得想想大学又是三年，高中四年，少年联盟还有三年。我大概有20多年的球龄了。
So you, 20 plus years of doing the same shit, you gotta think like, all right, I gotta figure out a way to do some other shit in order to stay in shape or to get my body right. So then I mean, you start getting creative. And I mean, you know, I would say realistically, maybe two, maybe three times in a gym a week and it ain't to do like, you know,
所以，20多年都在做同样的事情，你得想：好吧，我得想个办法做点别的什么来保持身材或者让我的身体恢复正常。然后我的意思是，你开始变得有创造力了。我的意思是，我会现实地说，一周大概去两、三次健身房，而且那可不是去做……
like you see that you probably be like pumping all this weights and all that shit. And it might be just to get a stretch, I mean, or to utilize this wonderful, but. Or just see who's in the steam. Yeah. Yeah, that should work too. Sign a statement for sure.
就像你看到的，你可能会觉得是在疯狂撸铁和搞那些破事。那可能只是为了做个拉伸，我是说，或者是为了利用这个美妙的，但是。或者只是看看谁在蒸汽浴室里。对。对，那招也管用。签名声明，绝对的。
But so I have like a, I have a two-part on my shan. So when you were playing football, was there a person or a moment that made you want to that kind of clicked your brain into, what if I did this, you know, expanded into entrepreneurial stuff? And what if I was there a person that you're like, gosh, I really admire the way he handled his career after football or during football,
所以我有这样一个，我有两个问题想问你，马肖恩。所以当你打橄榄球时，有没有哪个人或哪个时刻让你想要……让你的大脑灵光一闪，冒出“如果我这样做会怎么样”（比如拓展到创业领域）的想法？有没有哪个人让你觉得：天哪，我真的很佩服他在橄榄球赛后或橄榄球期间处理自己职业生涯的方式？或者有没有这样一个时刻？第二部分是，到目前为止，你最喜欢或最有成就感的创业尝试是什么？
or was there a moment? And the second part is, what is your favorite or most rewarding entrepreneurial effort so far? Yeah. Well, the first part is, before I even knew about money or anything, because it wasn't like that was something I came from.
好的，关于第一部分，在我甚至还不知道钱是什么或者别的什么之前，因为那并不是我出身的环境。
I remember that was having these financial advisors coming to the facility and get a spiel. I mean, you can choose a financial advisor that way. That was the way in which we met financial advisors. So the team brings people in to talk to players and sort of help them kind of figure out what they're doing. That's good, actually. Yeah, the player personnel, like, you know,
我记得当时有这些财务顾问来到训练基地进行推销。我的意思是，你可以通过那种方式选择财务顾问。这就是我们结识财务顾问的方式。所以球队会带人进来和球员交谈，并某种程度上帮他们搞清楚他们在做什么。这其实挺好的。对，球员人事部门，就像，你知道的，
the guy who looks after... Yeah. ...after the players on a more personal level. They'll bring in individuals who they know maybe through Dylan's wit or maybe got introduced by another player. But I remember the first time my financial advisor came in and he came in there and he was talking and shit, I had this thing where I could go to sleep, I could go to sleep, standing straight up.
那个更私密地照顾……对……照顾球员的人。他们会带一些人进来，这些人可能是通过迪伦的智慧认识的，也可能是由另一个球员介绍的。但我记得我的财务顾问第一次来的时候，他走进来开始滔滔不绝地讲那些破事，我当时有一种特异功能，我可以站着笔直地直接睡着。
So he came in and he started talking on a lot of, and I fell asleep. Yeah, I know' straight up. And so he came in and he started talkin' on La La and I fell asleep, and he got up. Because then one year out the other. Shit, it didn't go in no year. I'm sweet, dead to the world. Yeah. And he make a, he don't say no. So as he finish it up, and he, you know what I mean?
所以他进来开始滔滔不绝地讲，然后我就睡着了。对，我知道，笔直地站着。所以他进来开始讲个不停，然后我睡着了，他站起来了。因为那是左耳进右耳出。见鬼，根本没进耳朵。我睡得死沉死沉的。对。而且他也没说不。所以当他讲完时，你知道我的意思吗？
I kind of come to him up on the board. I see all these names. And these are names of NFL players who, you know, I thought, I kind of come to him up on the board, I see all these names. And these are names of NFL players who, you know, I thought if you play in NFL, you like a richest person in the world. I'm looking at all these names and I'm saying like, you know, they got a number on the side to the right of that name and another column. And I'm like, damn, like fuck, they got all this money. And then at the end of it, you know, you go through like three slides, I'm like, damn, like fuck, I got all this money. And then at the end of it, you know,
我有点清醒过来，走到黑板前。我看到了所有这些名字。这些都是NFL球员的名字，你知道的，我原本以为，我有点清醒过来，走到黑板前，我看到了所有这些名字。这些都是NFL球员的名字，你知道的，我原本以为如果你在NFL打球，你就是世界上最富有的人。我看着所有这些名字，心想，你知道的，他们的名字右边有一串数字，在另一栏里。我心想：见鬼，操，他们有这么多钱。然后在最后，你知道的，
we go through like three slides and I'm talking about maybe some of the most notable names and football. And at the end, he say, all bankrupt. And I'm like, what the fuck? Yeah, no money. I'm like, no, he'll know. Right.
我们看了大概三张幻灯片，我心想：见鬼，操，我有这么多钱。然后在最后，你知道的，我们浏览了大约三张幻灯片，我在说的可能是橄榄球界一些最有名的人。而在最后，他说，全都破产了。我当时想：这他妈什么情况？对，没钱了。我说：不，见鬼，不可能。对。
Now I'm up. Yeah. But now it's presentation time away. Yeah. I'm like, Hey, hold on. What do you mean they bankrupt? Like, you know, I seen some of the names of individuals who, you know, I looked up to, like, not what the fuck. So after he said, man, you slept through my whole meeting. I say, yeah, I did. I, you know, with my bad, but can you start from the
现在我清醒了。对。但现在是演讲时间，走开。对。我心想：嘿，等等。他们破产是什么意思？就像，你知道的，我看到了我一直崇拜的一些个人的名字，就像：这他妈什么情况？所以在他讲完之后，他说：伙计，你听我开会全程都在睡觉。我说：对，我是睡了，我知道，我挺抱歉的，但你能从……
beginning again? Where you said all my, all of these players up here is broke down. Like, what the fuck is going on? And the number next to them are the millions in debt they are. Yeah. Man, and I'm like, how do I not become good for you? Good for you. Good for you. You know what, Marcia? First of all, you can't go to sleep in my meeting.
头再讲一遍吗？就是你刚才说所有这些排在上面的球员都破产了的那段。这他妈到底是怎么回事？他们旁边的数字是他们欠下的几百万美元吗？对。伙计，然后我就想：我该怎么做才不会落得这种下场？做得好。做得好。做得好。你知道吗，马肖恩？首先，你不能在我的会议上睡觉。
How do you look? Right. Quit bringing up. Oh, shit. We talking about moving forward. Was there what was early on one of the, if you if you did make like a just foolish, you know, purchase. Do you remember like one of the dumbest things you've ever bought? You said one of the dumbest things I ever bought. Like when you first started out, you're like, oh, I got an extra, you know.
你最近怎么样？对。别提了。哦，操。我们正聊着往前看呢。早期的时候，如果你真做过什么很傻的，你知道的，购物决定。你还记得你买过最蠢的东西之一是什么吗？你刚才说我买过最蠢的东西之一。就像你刚开始的时候，你心想，哦，我多了一笔，你知道的。
Did you ever buy an animal that should probably be in a zoo? Yes. I have. But that didn't come. That wasn't really wrong. That was after everything was said. Oh, really? What kind of animal was this? I brought a monkey. A monkey? You didn't really? I always wanted a monkey.
你买过大概应该关进动物园的动物吗？对。我买过。但那不是。那其实没搞错。那是尘埃落定之后的事。哦，真的吗？这是什么动物？我买了一只猴子。一只猴子？你不会吧？我一直想要一只猴子。
What kind of monkey? Red hand, tamer. Is that true? Did you really buy one? Yeah, about as big as my hand. Little pep was his name. Oh, my God. Little pep.
什么种类的猴子？红手柽柳猴。真的假的？你真的买了一只？对，大概我手掌那么大。它叫小佩普。哦，天哪。小佩普。
That's allial apostrophe. Man, nah, no apostrophes. Is this the kind that throws stuff at you? No, I don't know, shit, ain't it? Now, he will get the, he will get the yellow that you don't. He'll yell. Really? Is he still with us?
那是带撇号的。伙计，不，没有撇号。这是那种会向你扔东西的猴子吗？不，我不知道，操，不是吗？不过，它会，它会发出你没见过的黄色。它会大叫。真的吗？它还跟我们在一起吗？
Hell yeah. No, no, no, no. See, they got a, they got a short life man. Yeah. I was always nervous. I wouldn't want to get, like, a mic would come and like end up like ripping my arms and my balls off for some reason. He was biggest my hand about as big as my hand.
当然在了。不，不，不，不。你看，它们的，它们的寿命很短，老兄。对。我一直很紧张。我可不想弄得，比如来个麦克，然后不知怎么把我的胳膊和蛋蛋都撕下来。它最大也就我手那么大，大概我手那么大。
And I mean this little more fuck was fascinating. Oh my God. He did some of the most crazy shit I've ever seen before. You have to get a trainer for that or do you train him yourself? No date to be honest, which we really he really cool though Like I mean, they come they come trained. No, they don't come on say that but as far as like I mean He's so little like if he take his shit somewhere. It's like Like a wreck like wreck. Yeah, right. Oh, he's like there's no mess. Yeah shit like that never diaper on little Pimp No, man. He wasn't we wasn't for finding me man. Little Pimp was he was a man. He was a real true. Oh
我是说这个小混蛋太迷人了。哦，天哪。它干过一些我见过最疯狂的破事。你得为此找个训练师，还是自己训练它？不用，说实话，我们真的，它其实挺酷的，我是说，它们来的时候，它们来的时候就是受过训练的。不，它们不是，我这么说吧，但就我而言，我是说 它太小了，如果它在哪拉了屎。这就跟……就像个灾难，就像灾难一样。对，没错。哦，它就像……根本没有弄脏。对，像那种从来不用给小皮普穿尿布。不，老兄。它不用，我们没给它穿，老兄。小皮普是个，它是个男人。它是个真正纯爷们。哦
Little Pimp RIP low Pimp RIP little Pimp, but there was a few I mean, there was a lot of guys that you know mean, I started to see Turn, you know, like you should watch O'Jane movies, Jim Brown and movies. And I mean, you know, just to see them being able to do it again, all this opportunity there to do that. And then, you know, throughout the lead, you know, you have players who, you know, getting into investments and like, hey, man, you know, I'm working with this company, you know, you have players who, you know, get into investments and like, hey, man, you know, I'm working with this company, you know, Blizzard. But I like you doing well.
小皮普，安息吧，小皮普。安息吧，小皮普。不过有那么几个，我是说，有很多人，你知道的，我开始看到转变，你知道的，就像你会看奥·杰西的电影，吉姆·布朗的电影。我是说，你知道的，看到他们能够再次做到这一点，所有的机会都在那里去实现。然后，你知道的，在整个联盟里，你知道的，有些球员，你知道的，开始涉足投资，就像，嘿，老兄，你知道的，我正在和这家公司合作，你知道的，你会看到球员，你知道的，涉足投资，就像，嘿，老兄，你知道的，我正在和这家公司合作，你知道的，暴雪。但我喜欢你干得不错。
Oh, yeah, you know, I'm an outreach person and like, okay, I'll reach like, well, I mean, you know, I don't really like people like that, but for the, for the simple fact that I'm seeing you being able to be on a level of professionalism even after you done playing football. You know, I kind of got inspired by that and I wanted to see what was actually out there. And a lot of this shit that I that I did learn or that I did get into it basically all started off like a joke kind of like, you know, damn, well, see if they let me get ownership. Right. Okay. And then it's like, okay, yeah, you put a couple dollars up and they get you some ownership. I, all right. Yeah, you did that. You did that with like the Seattle Kraken.
哦，对，你知道的，我是一个外联人员，就像，好吧，外联就像，嗯，我是说，你知道的，我其实不太喜欢那样的人，但出于，出于这么个简单的原因，我看到你即使在不踢橄榄球之后，也能保持在一个专业水准上。你知道的，我有点受到启发，我想看看外面到底有什么。而我所学到或涉足的很多破事，基本上都是从一个玩笑开始的，有点像，你知道的，妈的，好吧，看看他们能不能让我获得所有权。没错。好吧。然后就像，好吧，对，你出了一笔钱，他们就给你一些所有权。我，好吧。对，你做到了。你对西雅图海怪队就这么干过。
You got ownership in that. You know, Sean, you might not know this. Martian's like part owner of a bunch of sports teams, including the NHL Seattle crack. And Martian, I did this thing with for soccer for the World Cup last year. And then like like two weeks into it, he sends me this sweatshirt from the Oakland Roots. And I go, what's the end? And he goes, yeah, this, this MLS two team that I, I co-own and I go, we've been talking about soccer every day for two weeks. And you're only telling me now that you're an owner of a team.
你在那有所有权。你知道，肖恩，你可能不知道这一点。马肖就像是一堆运动队的联合老板，包括NHL的西雅图海怪队。而且马肖，我去年曾和这家伙一起为世界杯做过一件事。然后大概过了两周，他给我寄了一件奥克兰根基队的运动衫。我问，这是什么？他说，对，这是这个MLS二级联赛的球队，我联合拥有的。我说，我们每天都在谈论足球，已经谈了两周了。而你现在才告诉我，你是一支球队的老板。
That's what he's got all these pieces of these teams, which is so, so cool. Very cool. Very savvy. Yeah, no kidding. Like team ownership. That's, that's where it's at. Yeah, man. Just trying to, try to, try to position myself. I mean, I have, I have $1,000 to invest in a team. Can I see? Look, you just a little bit too late. We just did a round where we could have bought into a... That's a nickname, too late. Too late just. You could have bought into the Oakland roots. We just raised two million,
这就是他拥有所有这些球队股份的原因，太酷了。非常酷。非常有头脑。对，可不是嘛。就像球队所有权。这才是，这才是王道。对啊，老兄。只是想，想，想把自己摆正位置。我是说，我有，我有一千美元可以投资一支球队。我能看吗？看，你稍微晚了一点。我们刚完成一轮融资，本来你可以买入……这也是个外号，太晚了。太晚了，只是。你本可以买入奥克兰根基队。我们刚筹集了两百万，
in Oakland, more or so, like, you know, my team, my team, my city, it's something being going on within the Bay Area just because you know within the last what five years we don't know what the Raiders, the Warriors and I just I think I just heard the A's is leaving too. So wow. Yeah. Why don't you start why don't you start doing a show like like our friends Rob and Ryan and just have cameras following you around you go visit all the teams that you own pieces of. That'd be a good show. Yeah, that would be a good show, actually.
在奥克兰，更像是，你知道的，我的球队，我的球队，我的城市，湾区正在发生一些事情，因为你知道在过去的五年里，我们经历了突袭者队、勇士队，而且我好像刚听说运动家队也要走了。所以，哇。对。你为什么不开始，为什么不开始做一个像我们的朋友罗布和瑞恩那样的节目，让摄像机跟着你到处跑，你去参观你拥有股份的所有球队呢？那会是个好节目。对，那确实会是个好节目。
That's a good idea. Thank you. It's not a bad idea. Or podcasts. Thank you. We'll produce it through smartness media. Yeah, we will. Great.
这是个好主意。谢谢。这不是个坏主意。或者播客。谢谢。我们将通过Smartless媒体制作它。对，我们会制作的。太棒了。
We just made some money. What else was wrong? I came over here. I'm trying to see what we'll do. Here we go. Let's do the podcast. Go with you popping around and visiting on the teams that you own.
我们刚赚了点钱。还有什么不对劲的？我来到这里。我想看看我们要拍什么。我们开始吧。我们做这个播客吧。跟着你四处走动，参观你拥有的球队。
I want to hear locker room speeches. I want to hear play by play. So kinds of things. We wait a second. I wanted to ask you about locker room speeches because you worked with some great coaches. You worked with great players. You got to know that Martian's quarterback when he was at Cal was another than Aaron Rodgers and then his quarterback. While he was a pro for most of his career was Russell Wilson to the all-time great quarterbacks. Coach was, for a long time was Pete Carroll in Seattle. I mean, you've been, it's funny.
我想听更衣室里的演讲。我想听实况转播。诸如此类的事情。等等。我想问你关于更衣室演讲的事，因为你和一些伟大的教练合作过。你和伟大的球员合作过。你一定知道马肖在加州时的四分卫不是别人，正是阿伦·罗杰斯，然后他的四分卫。在他职业生涯的大部分时间里，他的四分卫是拉塞尔·威尔逊，两位史上最伟大的四分卫。很长一段时间里，他在西雅图的教练是皮特·卡罗尔。我是说，你一直，这很有趣。
It feel, I feel like sometimes like great players and towns are attracted to each other. And you got in with, you were with a lot of talented people. What was your relationship like with coaches? Well, specifically like Pete Carroll, but coaches in general through college and then into the pros. Early, early on in my career,
感觉，有时我感觉伟大的球员和城镇会彼此吸引。你加入了，你和许多才华横溢的人在一起。你和教练的关系怎么样？好吧，特别是像皮特·卡罗尔，还有整个大学期间以及进入职业联赛后的教练们。在我职业生涯的早期，
like from, I'm gonna go like this. Pob winter high school, it was easy because all the coaches was from my neighborhood and understand how to speak to me, understand how to get them all started me. Then going to college, consider, I ain't, because I ain't grow up with my father in the house. So going to college and then I have, you know, I mean, open at this time, probably 90%. Black, I got a white head coach
就像从，我这么说吧。波布，冬天的高中，这很简单，因为所有的教练都来自我的社区，懂得怎么跟我说话，懂得如何让我融入其中。然后去上大学，考虑到，我没有，因为我从小没有父亲在身边。所以去上大学，然后我有了，你知道我的意思，当时可能90%的黑人，我有一个白人主教练
and this motherfucker don't got no filter. And I'm talking about maybe one of the most, how could I say that? At the time, I thought like, I regretted it. I'm like, man, this motherfucker racist. I can't do nothing right. And then it was like, all of a sudden, it just clicked for me like, oh shit.
而这个混蛋根本没有滤镜。我是说，这可能是最，我该怎么说呢？当时，我以为，我很后悔。我想，天哪，这混蛋是个种族歧视者。我做什么都不对。然后就像，突然之间，我开窍了，哦，操。
And I ain't not racist. This dude was preparing me for going to the league and what I was not gonna go through on the real world. Knowing where I'm coming from, you know what I mean? I was basically trapped in a box and he was opening my mind to shit that I didn't even know exist. Coaching was something that I didn't take lightly,
他根本不是种族歧视。这家伙是在为我进入联盟做准备，为我在现实世界中将要经历的事情做准备。了解我的背景，你知道我的意思？我基本上被困在一个盒子里，而他在开阔我的眼界，去看那些我甚至不知道存在的破事。执教并不是一件我能轻易接受的事，
man, fuck you. How you gonna tell me what to do? Motherfucker, you ain't playing, you ain't, yeah, man. And then the running back coach that I had when I was in college, I found out he played DB, and I'm like, how the fuck you gonna tell me how to be the greatest running back in your motherfucking ass play DB? It didn't make sense to me, but what it did was it taught me to learn from individuals from different perspectives.
老兄，去你的。凭什么告诉我该怎么做？混蛋，你又不上场，你又没，是啊，老兄。然后我在大学时的跑卫教练，我发现他以前打的是防守后卫（DB），我就想，你特么怎么能教我怎么成为最伟大的跑卫，而你特么自己打的是DB？这对我来说根本讲不通，但它所做的是，它教会我向不同角度的个人学习。
He knew what it looked like as a running back, coming down here at a defensive back. He didn't know what it looked like as a running back, running down defensive back. He's able to tell me, when he tell me, my shine right here, square your shoulders up, he knew that BBs don't wanna tackle running back. No. So make him make a business decision. Make him stick his head through his shoulder pad.
他知道作为一个跑卫从这里冲向一个防守后卫是什么感觉。他不知道作为一个跑卫从防守后卫身边冲过去是什么感觉。他能够告诉我，当他告诉我，我的闪耀就在这里，把你的肩膀摆正，他知道DB不想去擒抱一个跑卫。不。所以要让他做出商业决定。让他把头塞进他的肩垫里。
Yeah. Make him wiggle his head through his shoulder pad. Doesn't work. Yeah, I mean, it doesn't work. But I wasn't in the movies. It hurts. Yeah, I wasn't paying attention to that early on, but like I said, when I figured it out,
对。让他把头在肩垫里扭来扭去。没用。对，我是说，没用。但我当时没拍电影。这很疼。对，我早期没注意到这一点，但就像我说的，当我弄明白之后，
okay, this shit makes sense now. We'll be right back. Smartlet's get support from Mint Mobile. Ever felt bill-induced anxiety, that looming cloud of stress that hangs over you. We get it. No one enjoys the relentless cycle of big monthly payments. I don't know who enjoys it.
好吧，这破事现在说得通了。我们马上回来。SmartLess获得Mint Mobile的支持。你是否感受过账单带来的焦虑，那种挥之不去的压力阴云。我们懂的。没人喜欢每月大额账单的无情循环。我不知道谁会喜欢。
Who raised your hand if you enjoy it? Nobody's has their hand. If you're looking for a wallet, friendly solution for your phone bill, Mint Mobile is the way forward. Mint Mobile offers premium wireless for just 15 bucks a month. All plans come with unlimited talk and text
谁，如果你喜欢请举手。没人举手。如果你正在为你的手机账单寻找一个对钱包友好的解决方案，Mint Mobile就是最佳选择。Mint Mobile提供优质无线服务，每月只需15美元。所有套餐都包含无限通话和短信
and high speed data delivered on the nation's largest 5G network. Use your own phone with any Mint Mobile plan and keep your same phone number along with all your existing contacts. By going online only and eliminating the traditional cost of retail, Mint Mobile passes significant savings on to you.
以及在全美最大的5G网络上提供的高速数据。在任何Mint Mobile套餐中使用你自己的手机，并保留你原有的手机号码以及所有现有的联系人。通过纯线上运营并消除零售的传统成本，Mint Mobile将巨额节省直接回馈给你。
Switch to Mint Mobile and get premium wireless service starting at just $15 a month. To get your new wireless plan for just $15 a month and get the plan shipped to your door for free, go to mintmobile.com-smartless. That's MintMobile.com-smartless. Cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month and let them know we sent you by going to MintMobile.com-smartless.
切换到Mint Mobile，享受每月仅需15美元起的优质无线服务。要以每月仅需15美元的价格获得你的新无线套餐，并免费将套餐配送到家，请访问mintmobile.com-smartless。这就是MintMobile.com-smartless。将你的无线账单削减至每月15美元，并通过访问MintMobile.com-smartless让他们知道是我们介绍你来的。
SmartLess is sponsored by ADT. ADT's self-setup features everything from motion sensors to Google Nest Cam's with no long-term contracts. Isn't that great? Easily install the ADT self-setup security system at your convenience. No heavy duty tools are needed. And if you need help, don't call me ADT can provide virtual assistance along the way. ADT's self-setup grows, moves, and adapts as your needs change. You can add more products at any time and your system easily moves wherever life takes you. It also features Nest Cam's
SmartLess由ADT赞助。ADT的自助安装功能应有尽有，从运动传感器到谷歌Nest摄像头，且没有长期合同。这不是很棒吗？在您方便的时候轻松安装ADT自助安装安全系统。不需要重型工具。如果您需要帮助，别给我打电话，ADT可以一路提供虚拟协助。ADT自助安装随着您的需求变化而增长、移动和适应。您可以随时添加更多产品，您的系统可以轻松随生活转移到任何地方。它还配备了Nest摄像头
that can tell the difference between a person, an animal, a vehicle, or with the Nest doorbell, even a package. Plus, when every second counts, you can trust ADT's 24-7 professional monitoring. You can view a video of an alarm event and verify or cancel an alarm with just a tap. When the most trusted name in home security adds the intelligence of Google, you've got a home with no worries. Go to ADT.com today or call 1-800-ADT-ASAP.
能够区分人、动物、车辆，或者通过Nest门铃，甚至可以区分包裹。此外，当每一秒都至关重要时，您可以信赖ADT的24/7专业监控。只需轻轻一按，您就可以查看警报事件的视频并验证或取消警报。当家庭安全领域最值得信赖的名字融入谷歌的智能技术时，您就拥有了一个无忧无虑的家。今天就访问ADT.com或致电1-800-ADT-ASAP。
Google, Nest Cam, Nest Doorbell, and Nestle Wear train marks of Google LLC. All right, back to the show. It seems to me that guy like Pete Carroll, does he coach, I feel like a lot of his speeches are really esoteric, like really out there kind of like, like are they football related or does he make a lot of like big sort of inspirational speeches about life? And is that, am I right on that? That he, I fuck with Pete, I'm one of the chapters here with him,
Google、Nest Cam、Nest Doorbell和Nest Aware是Google LLC的商标。好的，回到节目中来。在我看来，像皮特·卡罗尔这样的人，他执教时，我感觉他的很多演讲都非常高深莫测，就像非常超脱的那种，就像，它们是和橄榄球有关的，还是他发表了很多关于生活的宏大、励志的演讲？我是不是说对了？他，我挺受落皮特的，我和他拿过一个冠军，
but as far as speeches and all that, you know, I would? That, yeah, I fuck with Pete. I wanted to championship with him, but as far as speeches and all that, you know, I would, I would leave out of his meetings. Did you do any standing up sleeping in the Pete Carroll meetings? No, I sit down sleeping in that moment. Yeah, I'm like, I'm on my good race. It's digging in there.
但至于演讲和所有这些，你知道的，我会？那，对，我挺受落皮特的。我和他拿过一个冠军，但至于演讲和所有这些，你知道的，我会，我会离开他的会议。你在皮特·卡罗尔的会议上站着睡着过吗？不，我在那个时刻坐着睡着。对，我是说，我在保持状态。我在那死撑呢。
No, I would, yeah, I would, I would, you know, after a while, they just started become repetitive for me. Right. And then I'm not a guy who you need to like, ah, rar, rar, rar, rar, rar, that give me ready to go and bust them like, because I'm already at a disadvantage because that's what, that's what my lifestyle was.
不，我会，对，我会，你知道的，过了一会儿，对我和我来说这些开始变得重复了。没错。然后我不是那种你需要对我说“加油、加油、加油、加油、加油”才能让我准备好去冲撞他们的人，因为我在起点上就已经处于劣势了，因为那就是，那就是我的生活方式。
So I don't need that, that shit, that shit just gonna make me upset, make me like, all right, bro, you talking too much. Like, I don't wanna talk. I just wanna bust motherfuckers head. And you keep talking is, you damn near talking me out of going to go bust
所以我不需要那种狗屁，那种狗屁只会让我心烦，让我觉得，行了，兄弟，你废话太多了。我不喜欢说话。我只想把这帮混蛋的脑袋打爆。而你一直在那废话，简直快把我说的都不想去打爆
some motherfuckers head. Now, I wanna let them do something to you because you talk too much. I don't need, I don't need, rar, rar, rar. And he was, you know, that type of guy. So, you know, anytime I could eliminate the rar, rar, rar, I would, I would do that. But I mean, you know, I don't have some great coaches
那帮混蛋的脑袋了。现在，我想让他们对你做点什么，因为你废话太多了。我不需要，我不需要“加油、加油、加油”。他就是，你知道的，那种人。所以，你知道的，只要我能消除那些“加油、加油、加油”，我就会，我就会那么做。但我是说，你知道的，一路上我确实遇到了一些伟大的教练
along the way. You know, men who, who I feel has taught me, you know, the stand on principle morals and values, which I feel that that shit you know to stand on principle morals of values which I feel that That shit is a thing of the past like that shit is a myth if you hear somebody standing on principle More than values like for real. He did like he must be hella old or something like that ain't something right now That is look that ends good thing and they taught me that That walk to walk with conviction as a good thing. And they taught me that walk, to walk with conviction as a man. And you know, I hold conversations with them till this day.
那些人，我感觉他们教会了我，你知道的，坚守原则、道德和价值观，我觉得那些破事，你知道的，坚守原则、道德和价值观，我觉得那些破事已经成了过去式，就像那些破事是个神话一样，如果你听到有人在讲坚守原则、道德和价值观，说真的。他一定，他一定老得要命或者别的什么，肯定有什么不对劲。那就是，看，那是件好事，他们教会了我这一点。作为一个男人，要带着信念去走路，他们教会了我这一点，要带着信念作为男人去走每一步。而且你知道的，直到今天我还在跟他们保持交流。
Still, you know, I mean, contact with them and reach out to me, reach out to them, check on them. But I mean, you know, it's a funny thing because I mean, like I said, from my mindset before on the coach, like what you talking about right now, that shit don't concern me to, okay, now these are individuals who have lives, families, and they actually walk with a purpose.
依然，你知道我的意思，跟他们保持联系，联系我，联系他们，关心他们。但我是说，你知道的，这很有趣，因为我是说，就像我说的，从我以前对教练的心态来看，就像你现在说的那样，这些破事与我无关，直到，好了，现在这些人都有生活、有家庭，他们确实是在带着目标前行。
And I feel that, you know what I mean? Once I opened up my mind to that, thanks to Coach Tefer to seeing them for more than just telling me, okay, Martian, you gotta run through the big gap. You gotta run through the C gap, or you gotta cut back right here, and I took it for more than what it was worth. Shit started to open up for me.
我觉得，你知道我的意思吗？一旦我向这些敞开心扉，多亏了蒂弗教练，看到他们不仅仅是告诉我，好吧，马肖，你得从那个大空隙冲过去。你得从C空隙冲过去，或者你得在这里回切，我接受了它超出了它本身价值的东西。事情开始向我敞开。
And it was a big thing for me. You know what I mean? It's funny you talk about Pete Carroll because at the time, he had got another coach over there, Tom Cable. And that was like my connection. Tom Cable and Coach Sherman. Those were my connections to the team.
这对我很重要。你知道我的意思吗？你谈论皮特·卡罗尔很有趣，因为当时，他在那边招了另一个教练，汤姆·卡贝尔。那就像是我的纽带。汤姆·卡贝尔和谢尔曼教练。那是我与球队的纽带。
That was hard grab the information about what was going on because Pete was a little bit, he was too much for me. You know what I mean? Like, you wake, I'm telling you, you come in at, because I had weird ass hours when you start talking about the gym and shit. Like I would come into the locker room maybe at four o'clock in the morning and I go do some extra work, sign a steam room, maybe a little bike swimming
那是艰难地获取关于正在发生的事情的信息，因为皮特有点，他对我也有些太过了。你知道我的意思吗？就像，你醒来，我跟你说，你进来，因为当我开始谈论健身房之类的东西时，我的时间安排极其诡异。我可能在凌晨四点左右走进更衣室，去做一些额外的训练，蒸个桑拿，可能骑一会儿单车、游个泳
or whatever. And it'd be about five o'clock in the morning and I'll see Pete coming into the office and he, hey, buddy, how you doing? It's gonna be a great day today. He's like, hey, hey, what the fuck? Hey, look at his five o'clock in the morning, but cool out.
或者别的什么。大概是凌晨五点左右，我会看到皮特走进办公室，他会说，嘿，老朋友，你好啊？今天会是美好的一天。他就像，嘿，嘿，搞什么鬼？嘿，听着，现在才凌晨五点，冷静点。
And you're like, how long, man? I just seen this motherfucker didn't leave out of the facility until like 11, 12 o'clock at night. That means back at five. And he was leaving. Hey buddy, I'm going home. You have a great night.
你会想，怎么回事，老兄？我刚看到这混蛋直到晚上11点、12点才离开基地。这意味着他5点又回来了。而他正准备离开。嘿，老朋友，我要回家了。祝你今晚过得愉快。
I'll see you tomorrow. Make sure you ready for a long time. Ain't like, home on this month. Better this motherfucker. And then it ain't no difference when you see him at breakfast. He coming at meat in the same way. You see the mother fuck at lunch. The same way.
明天见。确保你做好长期奋战的准备。不像，这家伙回家了。最好离这混蛋远点。然后你吃早餐时见到的他也没两样。他开会时也是这样。你吃午饭时见到的那混蛋。也是这样。
You see him on a practice field. You see him after practice and the meat is after that. And when he going home, he the same way. And best believe if you dare to see him coming in the morning, it's just like that. That's my fuck got to be a robot. Merchant, tell me, do I remember this right? Did you spend an entire season
你在训练场上看到他。你在训练后看到他，开会也在那之后。当他回家时，他还是老样子。而且相信我，如果你早上敢碰巧撞见他，他依然是那个德行。这混蛋绝对是个机器人。马肖，告诉我，我没记错吧？你是不是花了一整个赛季
not talking to the media? A few seasons, which means a season. A few. Were you refused to talk to the media, right? What they do, what they do to make you take that position. What they did was they showed me who they was. They showed me who they was They showed me who they was and
不和媒体说话？几个赛季，也就是说一个赛季。好几个。你拒绝和媒体说话，对吧？他们做了什么，他们做了什么让你采取这种立场？他们做的是，他们让我看清了他们是谁。他们让我看清了他们是谁，他们让我看清了他们是谁
The thing like I said I started to stand on principal morals and values and Because I mean you know, like I said I was I was raised different. I seen things through different lenses And then I listened that you should come into the Rooms and they tell all the media, it is that in the third, they're not your friend, blaschette, blaschette, and then they'll double back and say, you gotta remember, no press is bad press. What the fuck?
就像我说的，我开始坚守原则、道德和价值观，因为我是说，你知道的，就像我说的，我的教育背景不同。我透过不同的镜头看事情。然后我听见你们来到房间里，告诉所有媒体，就是这样那样，他们不是你的朋友，废话连篇，然后你们又转过头来说，你得记住，没有坏消息就是好消息。这特么算什么？
So that was a conflict for me. And then you had a situation where, it was a point in my career where everybody wasn't fucking with me, where I was doing shit that you would think 20 year old with, you know what I mean, with a couple of dollars in this pocket. So my stakes that would be made and it would go from, I'd be here one day, hey, my shine you, you're greatest, uh, this is the third, uh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
所以这对我来说是个矛盾。然后你遇到了这种情况，在我职业生涯的某个时期，每个人都不把我当回事，我做了一些你觉得一个20多岁、你知道的，口袋里揣着几个钱的小伙子会做的事。所以我犯下的错误会被放大，前一天我还在，嘿，马肖，你是最棒的，呃，就是这样那样，呃，对，对，对，对，对，对，对，
and then I get in trouble and then it was like, oh, I knew that motherfucker was a duck. Oh, that motherfucker ain't shit. Oh, fuck him. He needs to be in jail, not on the football. And then it was all this shit started to, and I'm like, damn, this the same motherfucker who I just saying last week was just telling me how much of a good run.
然后我惹上麻烦了，接着就像，哦，我早就知道那混蛋是个懦夫。哦，那混蛋根本不是东西。哦，去他的。他应该去坐牢，而不是去打橄榄球。然后所有这些破事都开始冒出来，我想，操，这就是上周刚夸我是个多么优秀的跑卫、
And, you know what I mean, he looked forward to seeing where it comes out next week and then, motherfucker. Fuck that. motherfucker make a mistake. Or a motherfucker got caught doing some shit he shouldn't have been doing. But the thing was, I seen how judge mental they was. And the thing was,
而且，你知道我的意思，他很期待看到我下周表现的同一个混蛋。然后，混蛋。去他的。混蛋犯了个错误。或者混蛋被抓到做了不该做的事。但关键是，我看到了他们有多么好为人师。关键是，
are when y'all not recording and doing all of that shit, is he, and I'm, hold on, you motherfuckers, it's too confusing. It's too confusing to try to find out who you individuals truly are. So in my terms instead of, I'm thinking like, you know what I mean, if we was back in the hood, and God beat your waves. But you know, I roll your ass up, I take your camera,
当你们没有在录音和搞那些破事的时候，他是不是，等等，你们这群混蛋，这太令人费解了。要弄清楚你们这些个人究竟是谁，实在是太令人费解了。所以按照我的方式，而不是像，你知道的，如果我们回到贫民窟里，上帝会平息你的风波。但你知道，我把你卷起来，我拿走你的相机，
all the, and it was like, oh, no, you can't, you can't do that. You can't act that way. So it was more and so like, hey, if you ain't got nothing nice to say, don't say nothing at all. Now these individuals who, you know, talking big shit about me, I could care less with anybody else thinking about me.
所有的，然后就像，哦，不，你不能，你不能那样做。你不能那样行事。所以更多的是像，嘿，如果你说不出什么好听的话，那就什么也别说。现在这些人在我背后说三道四，我对别人怎么看我根本不在乎。
And if this is my way to get people to understand where I'm coming from in X, Y, and Z, nah, fuck that. Who I need to deal with, I talked to them individuals, let them know what's up, and then I just go about my business. I didn't feel I needed to broadcast it to the gym. Exactly. Well, sadly, we live, we live in times where, we're obviously, we're sort of negativity sales. I've seen movie reviews that start off with a negative headline, and then you read it, and it's like not a bad review.
如果这是让人们理解我的背景和A、B、C的方式，不，去他的。我需要跟谁打交道，我就跟那些人谈谈，让他们知道怎么回事，然后我就忙我自己的事去了。我觉得我没必要向全世界广播。确实。唉，可悲的是，我们生活在，我们生活在一个显然，我们这种负面新闻比较好卖的时代。我看到过一些电影评论，开头是一个负面的标题，然后你读了之后，发现其实并不是一篇差评。
And I'm like, oh, you just wanted people to click on the shit, and people just want that kind of shit, which sucks. And it's not positive. I will say this, one of the great positive things you do, I know, Marshawn, you've got your famed first family foundation, which is pretty awesome. And I know you've been doing a lot of giving back through that. You want to talk about that for a little bit, which is pretty awesome. And I know you've been like doing a lot of giving back through that.
我就想，哦，你只是想让人们点击那些破事，人们就喜欢那种破事，这太烂了。而且一点也不积极。我得这么说，你所做的一件非常棒的积极的事，我知道，马肖，你有著名的第一家庭基金会，这真的很棒。我知道你通过它回馈了很多社会。你想稍微谈谈那个吗，这真的很棒。我知道你通过它回馈了很多社会。
You want to talk about that for a little bit, how that came to be. Well, yeah, that's probably the longest standing business that I got. And probably the, I mean, that's, I started that immediately, where I'm not going to say, we started that immediately after I decided to enter the draft. And I mean, since then, we just been on a tear. Like, I mean, it didn't matter wherever the help was needed. We tried to
你想稍微谈谈那个是怎么来的吗？好吧，是的，那可能是我拥有时间最长的业务。可能，我是说，我一开始就启动了那个，我不会说，我们是在我决定参加选秀后立即启动的。我是说，从那以后，我们就一直在全速前进。我是说，无论哪里需要帮助，我们都会去
feel that gap. And what specifically, like, what's the mission? Like, who you got, who you trying to help? Like what's the main? The inner city youth, we looked at a lot of the kids from our neighborhood. They don't get a fair shot. So we just tried to, even it up a little bit by, supplying some of the needs that they need in order to, I mean, be able to compete with somebody from a higher background or education level.
填补那个空白。具体来说，比如，使命是什么？比如你带着谁，你想帮助谁？主旨是什么？内城区的青少年，我们关注了我们社区的很多孩子。他们没有得到公平的机会。所以我们只是试图通过提供他们所需的一些物资来稍微拉平一点，为了，我是说，能够与来自更高背景或教育水平的人竞争。
And I mean, it just started as a football camp, but then it turned into architect camps. We do our architect camp for the kids over at Cal, shout out to Cal for let us utilize the facilities. We do, you know, reading programs, math programs, entrepreneur programs, we got Shopify, supply this with some shit, and we do Beast Mode of Business where they create
我是说，它最初只是一个橄榄球训练营，但后来演变成了建筑营。我们为加州的孩子们举办建筑营，向加州大学致敬，感谢他们让我们使用这些设施。我们做，你知道的，阅读项目、数学项目、创业项目，我们有Shopify为我们提供一些赞助，我们还做野兽模式商业项目，让他们创建
their own business and, you know, able to have it go live on Shopify site. I mean anything that you could think of from coding to fucking building a shoe creating clothing lives. I mean teaching them ways in order to you know think outside the box of what you know I mean the fight we call it the 580 and the 880. But to think outside of that and show them many ways like with the production company, everybody think like you gotta be the individual
他们自己的业务，你知道的，能够在Shopify网站上上线。我的意思是你能想到的任何事情，从编写代码到他妈的做鞋子、创立服装品牌。我的意思是教导他们各种方法，让你知道，跳出你所知道的框框去思考，我的意思是，这场战斗我们称之为580和880。但是要跳出这个框框去思考，并向他们展示许多方法，比如通过制作公司，每个人都认为你必须成为那个独立个体
that's on the screen to make them like, they don't know that there's a guy back there holding a mic, that there's a guy holding a camera, that you got grips, that you got motherfucking A.D.'s and all these like all these everything like I said I'm watching y'all right now to see I see two people on this but like they don't they don't know this all they see is they're gonna see the clip go for me talking my bullshit to well to you to and that's all they're gonna see and say all I want to do that not knowing it's a whole team that may all of you should come to this.
出现在屏幕上的人才能出名，他们不知道后面有个家伙拿着麦克风，有个家伙扛着摄像机，有灯光师，有特么的副导演以及所有这些，所有一切，就像我说的，我现在看着你们俩，我看到两个人在这，但他们，他们不知道这些，他们看到的只是他们会看到一个剪辑片段，从我说我的废话到，到你，到你，而这正是他们所看到的，并说“我只想那样做”，却不知道是一个团队促成了你们所有人来到这里。
Yeah, there's actually a lot of group of people that are making it. The people on screen are just in it, you know. Jason, you said this once and I love this. Everybody on set, when you go on a movie, everybody from catering to background holding to locations, to team studs, driver, you know, everybody's a filmmaker, right? Everybody on that set is a filmmaker and it's what makes us know.
对，实际上是一大群人在促成这件事。屏幕上的人只是参与其中而已。杰森，你曾经说过这话，我特别喜欢。片场每个人，当你拍电影时，从餐饮到群演，到现场制片，到车队司机，你知道的，每个人都是电影人，对吧？片场每个人都是电影人，这就是让我们……
No one there that doesn't need to be there. That's exactly right. I love, Marshall, I love that you're doing that and it doesn't surprise me because I know, you know, I got to know you're in such a great guy. And, man, I'm just, it's so great to be able to talk to you. We've, I'm, we've held you here too long, kind of held you hostage, but I just want to, I can, No, I told you you might, you, you folks, Brad, you, you good in the hood, man, anytime. So, well, it's, it's good. I have no problem with that.
没有一个人是在那儿多余的。完全正确。马肖，我太喜欢你这么做了，这并不让我惊讶，因为我知道，你知道的，我逐渐发现你是个这么棒的家伙。而且，老兄，我只是，能跟你谈话真是太棒了。我们，我，我们在把留在这儿太久了，有点像把你当人质了，但我只是想，我能，不，我告诉过你，你，你们，布拉德，你在社区里混得很好，随时奉陪。所以，好吧，挺好的。我对此没有意见。
Marcia, you're the best, man. Thank you, continued success. Thank you, Marcia. You're just, you're just always, always you. Yeah, yeah. And we'll talk soon. Thanks for being here. Thank you, Marcia. All good, man, y'all have a blessed day talk soon. Thanks for being here. Thank you, Marciani.
马肖，你太棒了，老兄。谢谢你，祝你百尺竿头更进一步。谢谢你，马肖。你总是，总是那么真性情。对，对。我们很快再聊。谢谢你能来。谢谢你，马肖。一切都好，老兄，祝你们过个美好的一天，回聊。谢谢你能来。谢谢你，马肖。
All good, man. Y'all have a blessed day, man. Nice meeting you too. Thank you, Marciani. What a sweet fella. What a great guy, huh? Yeah. How cool is it that here's a guy who has not just a football career, but he wins Super Bowl
一切都好，老兄。祝你们过个美好的一天，老兄。很高兴认识你。谢谢你，马肖。多讨人喜欢的家伙。真是个棒小伙，对吧？对啊。这有多酷啊，这不仅是一个拥有职业生涯的家伙，他还赢得了超级碗
and he goes to Pro Bowl and he's a first team goal. Pro does every, like every basically thing he can do as an NFL player. Superstar. And then has this retires three times, by the way, like every basically thing he can do as an NFL player. Superstar. And then has this retires three times by the way, retired because he kept coming back. And then he retires and he turns, he turns all that into becomes this entrepreneur and he goes into, it goes into the arts and goes into all this stuff. And I'm like, this dude is unbelievable. He truly is.
他去过职业碗，而且是一阵球员。做到了，就像他作为一个NFL球员基本上能做到的所有事情。超级巨星。然后经历了这个，顺便说一句，他退役了三次，就像他作为一个NFL球员基本上能做到的所有事情。超级巨星。然后经历了这个，顺便说一句，退役了三次，因为他总是复出。然后他退役了，他把这一切，把所有这些都转化为了成为一名企业家，他涉足艺术，涉足所有这些领域。我就觉得，这家伙太不可思议了。他真的是这样。
He's gone beast mode through life. Not just on the football field. Yeah, yeah. He's just gone beast mode into life. Not just a football field. Yeah, yeah. He's just gone beast mode into everything he does. And I have so much respect for the guy. He's such a cool dude. Sounds like he didn't need to. He held onto his money. And he probably doesn't need to continue working so hard, but that's just part of his makeup. Yeah. Yeah. I love that, too. He's such a savvy dude. And he's just so cool. And again, I should point out he's such a good, good person to. So I'm lucky.
他把野兽模式贯穿了整个人生。不仅仅是在橄榄球场上。对，对。他把野兽模式带入了生活。不仅仅是橄榄球场。对，对。他把野兽模式带入了他所做的每一件事中。我对这家伙充满了敬意。他真是个太酷的家伙了。听起来他其实不需要这样。他守住了自己的财富。他可能不需要继续这么拼命工作，但这只是他性格的一部分。对。对。我也很喜欢这一点。他是个太有头脑的家伙了。而且他真的很酷。再次强调，我得指出他也是个非常好非常棒的人。所以我很幸运。
I'm lucky that you came. I didn't like it. I know him. Yeah. He seems very kind. Yeah. He is very kind. Did you guys see Jason's headline the meltdown thing?
我很幸运你来了。我不喜欢这样。我认识他。对。他看起来非常善良。对。他非常善良。你们看到杰森的头条新闻那个精神崩溃的事情了吗？
Yeah. Yeah. The little stuff you guys chopped together and put on the show. It's like, it's not as meltdown on, but I mean, it's just. What are you talking about? No, it's, it's, it's, no, no, I know. But it, to your point earlier, you said in the interview here that people will find a headline just so you can click through.
对。对。你们拼凑起来并放在节目上的那些小片段。这感觉不像是什么精神崩溃，但我的意思是，只是。你在说什么呢？不，这，这，这，不，不，我知道。但正如你刚才所说，你在这里的采访中说过，人们会为了让你点击而捏造一个头条新闻。
Yeah, click it. And the fact that I said in it that I had a full meltdown, they were able to use that, put out around it, and then say, Bateman has quote, full meltdown on podcast. So it's dumb. It's the headline they need. Yeah, it's good.
对，点进去。而事实是，我在采访中说我彻底崩溃了，他们就能利用这一点，围绕它大做文章，然后说：“贝特曼在播客中‘彻底崩溃’”。这太蠢了。这就是他们需要的头条。对，挺好的。
It's good press for us, I guess. I haven't looked on the internet. And I'm so stymied by that. Well, you'd need a Google alert on smartless and or me. Oh, I'm going to get one. I'm going to look into that. I might least one. You're going to lease a Google alert.
这对我们来说算是好的宣传吧。我还没上网看呢。我对此感到非常困惑。好吧，你需要在Smartless和/或我身上设置一个谷歌快讯（Google Alert）。哦，我要去弄一个。我要研究一下。我可能会租一个。你要去租一个谷歌快讯吗？
Yeah, what is it cost you to get into one of those? Well, the rental's pretty steep, but... Uh, well, you know what though? Maybe you can, yeah. Yeah, go ahead. No, you're gonna do it for the first time. Oh, it's gonna say maybe you can't, if you can't pull, you can't afford a full subscription,
对，弄一个那玩意儿要花多少钱？嗯，租金挺高的，不过……呃，不过你知道吗？也许你可以，对。对，说吧。不，你这是第一次要这么做。哦，我本来要说也许你不能，如果你不能全额订阅，
maybe you could do a, Bye, monthly! Bye! Bye, monthly! Why are you holding your stomach, bye? You have an ape from and T-shirt on, that's pretty good. Sausage Kanga Chicago. That's right.
也许你可以做个，按月！再见！按月！你为什么捂着肚子，再见？你穿着一件Ape From的T恤，那挺不错的。芝加哥香肠卡加（Sausage Kanga Chicago）。没错。
Jason say bye. Bye. Yeah. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
杰森说再见。再见。对。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armstrong, and Bennett Barberco.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。Smartless是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆斯特朗和班尼特·巴伯科100%有机且手工制作的。
Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wendry plus in Apple podcasts or the Wendry app. Okay, so if you had a time machine, how far in time would you need to go back to be a dominant basketball player of that year. I need to go to when Bob Coosie was playing. I would. In the plumber day, 27 year old Shay would give Bob Coosie the business. He's not guarding me. Hi, I'm Jason G'Zepsione. And I'm Shay Serrano. And we are back.
我们的下一期节目将在的一周后发布，你可以在你收听播客的任何地方收听，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts上的Wondery Plus或Wondery应用来享受无广告的抢先收听。好了，如果你有一台时间机器，你需要回到过去多久，才能成为那一年的统治级篮球运动员？我得回到鲍勃·库西打球的时候。我会的。在水管工的时代，27岁的谢伊绝对会把鲍勃·库西打得落花流水。他可防不住我。嗨，我是杰森·吉泽普西奥尼。我是谢伊·塞拉诺。我们回来了。
We have a new podcast from Wondering. It's called Six Trophies. And that's the best. Each week, Shay and I are coming through all of the NBA storylines, finding the best, most interesting, most compelling ones, and then handing out six pop culture theme trophies for six basketball related activities. Trophies like the Dominic Toretto,
我们带来了Wondery的一个新播客。它叫《六座奖杯》（Six Trophies）。太棒了。每周，我和谢伊都会梳理所有的NBA故事情节，找出最好、最有趣、最引人注目的故事，然后为六项与篮球相关的活动颁发六个流行文化主题的奖杯。比如多米尼克·托雷托奖杯，
I live my life in a quarter mile at a time trophy, which is given to someone who made a short-term decision with no regard to future cons quits. Or the Christopher and all intented trophy, which is given to someone who did something that we didn't understand. Catalina wine mixture trophy. Ooh, the Lauren Hill, you might win understand. Catalina Wine Mixer trophy.
“我的人生以四分之一英里为单位”奖杯，颁发给那些做出短期决定而完全不考虑未来后果的人。或者克里斯托弗·“有意为之”奖杯，颁发给那些做了我们无法理解的事情的人。卡塔利娜葡萄酒混酿奖杯。哦，劳伦·希尔“你可能会赢，但你刚刚输了一场”奖杯。卡塔利娜葡萄酒混酿奖杯。
Ooh, the Lauren Hill you might win some, but you just lost one trophy. Follow six trophies on the Wondering app or wherever you get your podcasts. Equalism to six trophies, add free right now by joining Wondering Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
哦，劳伦·希尔“你可能会赢，但你刚刚输了一场”奖杯。在Wondery应用或你获取播客的任何地方关注《六座奖杯》。立即加入Wondery Plus无广告收听《六座奖杯》。本期节目暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。